an example of AI being used to generate
new ideas can be seen in this simple
example here so I recently created a
style frame for a fictional TV series
called Black Rose and I needed to create
a title card for it so I wanted to start
with a image as a base and then work
around that image and how I did that
with AI is I went in and typed in a
prompt and you can see it started to
generate images so before AI I would
have been searching stock photography
sites to find an image to start with I
probably would have searched for Rose
images which I then would have cut out
and duplicated I would have searched for
field images maybe poppy fields whatever
it is to create a field here and then I
would have searched for you know castles
and backgrounds and things like that to
blur out and put in the background plus
disguise I would have had to composite
this entire image together from multiple
photographs or 3D renders to create this
it would have taken me hours if not days
to do that with AI I can create an image
like this within seconds